是松紧腰前面开个叉
前面开个叉
来腰尾的话是66
可以拉伸到82
臀尾的话是96
可以拉伸到100
来群场的话是83
咋弄点还没弄上
好好好
来来来
这一款谁要谁来抠
谁要谁来抠
9块9块抠7
两边有口袋
来藏青色的这个裙
面料软软的
它单层有点像真空棉的
但是它是单层
来谁要谁来抠9块9块
抠0抠0抠0
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块抠0
先往有个位移很好的面料
先往走了吗先往
来这个有个吊带裙
有个吊带裙
来这一款吊带裙吊带裙
谁要配裙子里面穿
这个不知道是不是包上去的
配衣服的
我不敢卖了都
别卖了别卖了
人家配衣服的完蛋了
衣服配不上
哎呀
光年
好了好了
终于好了
我的妈呀
姐妹们
来这个卫衣
来给宝贝们看一下
这个是L码
吊牌价6500
税入7150
来这个L码
它是一个棉35聚质65的
棉35聚质65
牌子是这个牌
来这个牌子
这个牌子的
来这个卫衣
这个等一下给那个漂亮威尼熊
她家儿子可以穿
吊带
刚才吊带啥样的
我估计可能是个裙子里边的
我给你看看
我不敢卖了这个
不敢卖了
感觉应该是
卫衣多少钱
卫衣的话你要给你29吧
29吧
本来要卖39的
来这个吊带
裙
带子可以调节
带子可以调节的
来胸围
胸围92
腰尾的话是108
之前你们这个
买了这个长裙
来
长度的话是113
它有的是没有衬的
这个估计是配那个贵货的
因为这个
我是从彤彤那边拉过来的
知道吧
然后这个可能是配那个
有一个100多的
面料锯纸
有个100多的裙子
有一个大红的
有个黑的那个裙
应该是配那个里面的
大阿家的38码
面料是锯纸的
你要吗
你要的话给你19
本来我想说29的算了
你要的话给你19吧
便宜点给你算了
没有他就不配就不配了
不配裙
不配衬的话
他应该便宜点
配衬裙的话
他就要贵一点
19你看你要我尝的
尝的
之前有到过一批这种吊带
都是要卖29
来我一给你看看
苹果气泡
我那个是蓝色
你蓝色配黑的是可以配的
蓝色配黑色是可以配的
来圆领圆领
人家有的白的里面都配黑
这个属于一个
灰色
你来了
紫龟好久不见
后面白色花卷
半斤给我看看好的
稍等一下下
好久不见
亲爱的
好
这个给你了
来
这个上面写的是L吊牌价
7000多呢
给你检查一下
来亲爱的390
刚才卡其的卡其那个19
卡其的那个给19
来321好谢谢
卡其的那个位置
你要不就那里脏了一点
其实你可以买一个魔术贴
买一个魔术贴给他贴一下
那个就可以了
就买一个什么字母的那种魔术贴
看看就在这个位置
稍微等我一下下紫龟
看看
搞不好你回家洗一下
不是
这那个啥也不能沾到这个上面
对吧
这个这一看就是没有穿过的
这一看就是新的没抓过的
好了
这不是不是
这个不是他可能就是说染色的时候
他可能做了什么
有颜色深的不小心滴上去一个
这个有可能
你知道我说的是啥
你说的是姨妈吗
哈哈哈哈
是不是啊
你买一个小字母啥的一个好看的标
给他往这里一贴
如果洗不掉的话
那你如果能洗掉的话
那最好了
对不对
是不是你说的是吧
你们
不是那个啥吧
我就想着是这个啥
我想我是
啊是伤口弄上去的吧
应该不是
想要利夫妇
哈哈哈哈
来这个芝芝给你看一下
啊想象力太丰富了
有的时候我跟你说真的不知道在想啥呢
来用后面再松紧腰
不像血迹我感觉
就到像那种油漆的感觉
我给你量一下啊
芝芝
来腰围64可以拉到76
腿围的话是腿围不限啊
群场的话是79
来这个是39
芝芝
面料是锯纸的啊
看来就是这种沙沙的
沙沙的啊
这种面料
来吧芝芝
有缝接够有拉链
确定不是红色的那啥
就给我
还是刺绣啊
是印花不是刺绣
我
我感觉像油
油漆
就是那种染色深的
我估计他肯定他们厂里面还有别的染色
就是别的颜色上面滴上去的
好
对对芝芝好久没见了
对对
不客气
谢谢你
再给你看看
是硬的感觉吗
不是
软的
软的感觉
我都想把我的手搞破给你滴一滴干了
看到了没有
你看看
就是像颜色像像那种咖色
就是像那种深咖色的
你知道吧
不小心滴上了一个深咖色
我感觉能洗掉
我给你搓一搓啊
要不然我用水给你搓一搓看能不能洗掉
行吗
那这服务到位吧
我看一下感觉好洗
但是我这边就是啥也没有了
没有那个洗洗衣液啊洗洁精啥玩意
没有只有只有水
只有水
你没等我一下姐妹妹
还能不能洗掉
淡了一点
别人冷水到位
看到了吗
有没有淡一点啊
我就是用手硬搓的
你回家用点洗衣液啥的
我感觉就是咖色滴上去的
我这没有没有用热水
咖色滴上去的
你看你看干嘛
如果真的洗不掉
那就用一个什么标给他标给他贴一下
你看看你再考虑一下没事的
我画后面给他晾一晾
我这没有洗洁精也没有洗衣液啥的
就是说不是很好洗
没事弄不掉也不要你
只要是染料
染料染料我确定肯定是染料
不是血迹
来这一款看一下这个
这个牌子的
尼龙100的我一摸这个就是尼龙100的这个牌子
尼龙100M码
干了给我
好的
洗衣皂洗对尼龙100M码M码
来这个夹个让我明天给你
刚好明天帮我开张
来来反正明天不发货要后天发
两边有这个前面有口袋
前面有口袋前面有口袋
尼龙100的M码M码这一款
来这个好看
胸围130134来长度的话66
长度66
先谢谢你了
明天帮我开张
来这一款谁要谁来扣2929扣6
2929哇这个好看我觉得
这个我觉得蛮好看的
谁要谁来扣29扣个6
29扣个6
这个可以防晒的啊夏天
夏天出门可以防晒又防水
又防晒又防水
还没过
对呀我得想着明天呀不然的话
没有开张的我都
一来上班你不知道
就开始焦虑了你懂吗快乐9999
就开始焦虑了啊今天怎么办如果
如果不能开张怎么办
愁死了
这个你们说男孩子能穿吗我儿子能穿吗
我感觉蛮好看的
那天给他留了一件了
昨天给他留了一件了
有男孩子穿好看模样给我儿子在留着呢这个尼龙的
还有的时候骑车的下雨了不喜欢打伞
那一袋往头上一袋
你们咋不说话呢帮我参谋参谋
帮我参谋一下
啊
来来来4l的面料锯纸的腰上有抽绳有松紧腰
两边有口袋直筒裤直筒裤面料锯纸啊来腰围腰围
8686可以拉伸到102
腿围140可以拉到146140146短了吧我儿子小
来来当场43裤长106我儿子个子不高
来这款谁要3939扣8但是
他你飘的你别看小这个不行那个不行
他不行了
转的不特留
来这个喊他来试试去新疆还没回来了要估计得十五六号能才能回来
来这一款来给宝宝看下有酷有贵的这个马甲底下是沙的
底下是沙的沙的欧根沙的啊来这个马甲有会有会啊来这款马甲来胸围胸围
腰围八十八十二腰围八十八十二来长度七十一长度七十一啊来这款谁要二十九二十九扣一扣一啊
来喜欢的姐姐就扣二十九扣个一二十九扣个一
扣一扣一哎呦
这一框是我走从头到尾拉过来
我看这底下有没有啥宝贝
他要是喜欢拍